vi ringrazio per il caloroso benvenuto
scusate per il ritardo ma non si trovava
parcheggio e non sapevo dove lasciare il
mio modulo lunare
beh è un po ingombrante è vero ma il suo
fascino anni 69 72
qual è il prezzo che è costato averlo
d'altra parte l'intero programma apollo
il programma della nasa per mandare
l'uomo sulla luna è costato oltre 45
miliardi di dollari attuali ne sono
rimasti diversi esemplari dopo che nel
1972 il programma è stato chiuso da
parte della nasa da per i contribuenti
americani proprio per mancanza di
finanziamenti
eppure questo tutto ciò quello che tutto
ciò che il programma pollo ha portato ha
cambiato la nostra vita quotidiana
la domanda che viene spesso fatta perché
spendiamo miliardi di dollari per
mandare tre uomini sulla luna
quando questo la gente c'è qui sulla
terra c'è gente che muore di fame
beh se state vedendo questa
presentazione sullo schermo dallo
schermo di un computer avete già questa
risposta
d'altro canto nel corso della storia è
sempre stato così viaggi esplorativi da
prima considerati uno spreco di soldi si
sono poi rivelati essere fondamentali
per la creazione del mondo attorno a noi
è stata la curiosità della nostra specie
a creare il mondo attorno a noi
circa 74 mila anni fa proprio la voglia
di esplorare ci ha salvato dopo che
un'eruzione super vulcanica ha portato
quasi all'estinzione la nostra stessa
specie
da quel momento in poi i viaggi di
esploratori come idea come leaf ericsson
sono diventati parte della nostra storia
e spinti da uomini coraggiosi pronti a
rischiare qualsiasi cosa partendo senza
nemmeno conoscere una meta lo spazio
però è intrinsecamente più difficile da
raggiungere di moltri altri luoghi e per
questo motivo che la fisica è corsa in
aiuto degli esploratori consentendo di
costruire bascelli d'esplorazione sulle
leggi conosciute dell'universo come la
stazione spaziale
ma perché così importante la fisica
l'avviso che viene spesso considerata da
coloro che non l'hanno mai osservata da
vicino come un qualcosa di astruso come
un qualcosa di difficilmente
comprensibili
le senza una logica particolare è troppo
complicato per essere utilizzato in
qualche modo dove è però tutto il
fascino che coloro che la studiano ci
trovano
beh la verità è che tutti i fisici non
sono nient'altro
anche gli amanti della fisica che
bambini bambini che non sono mai
cresciuti spinti dalla stessa curiosità
che in tenera età ci porta a fare
domande su qualsiasi cosa
la differenza è che stavolta al posto di
usare la lingua dell'uomo usiamo la
lingua certa la lingua dell'universo una
matematica
un esempio di fenomeni che ci possono
sembrare controintuitive che vengono
spiegati con la lingua della matematica
è proprio la caduta dei gravi
siamo portati a pensare che una piuma un
martello cadano a velocità diverse
d'altra parte come fa una piuma accadere
la stessa velocità di un martello o di
una palla da bowling
beh le equazioni e la realtà però non
sono apparentemente ci dimostrano il
contrario
prendiamo un attimo le uniche due
equazioni che vedrete mai in questo talk
l'energia potenziale gravitazionale di
un corpo cioè quanto energia un corpo
può avere dentro sottoposto alla forza
di gravità e l'energia cinetica di un
corpo ovvero quanta energia il corpo
effettivamente a ora l'energia
potenziale si indica con la formula mgh
dove m la massa del corpo stesso
g e l'accelerazione gravitazionale una
costante per il nostro pianeta e h che
l'altezza da cui facciamo cadere
l'oggetto mentre l'energia cinetica si
indica mezzo ai menu quadro dove vi è
proprio la velocità che vogliamo
calcolare ora quando un corpo cade
quello che succede in effetti è che
questi due l'energia che il corpo può
avere si trasforma in quella che il
corpo realmente a e quindi possiamo
uguagliare queste due equazioni e
scopriamo che la dipendenza dalla massa
scompare mangiamo l'equazione e possiamo
osservare effettivamente come la
velocità di caduta ma per chi allora la
velocità di caduta di un corpo non
dipende dalla massa beh perché un corpo
tanto più massiccio
con tanta più forza sarà attratto verso
terra giusto ma al contempo per il
principio d'inerzia sarà anche più
difficile ad accelerare e ciò si
compensa ma allora perché vediamo in
atmosfera che questi due oggetti che ad
una velocità diverse beh è l'aria l'area
qin gan con una diversa superficie
densità e velocità dei corpi essi
interagiscono e vengono rallentati in
modo diverso e quindi noi effettivamente
siamo ingannati a questa prima
intuizione ci arrivò galileo galilei nel
corso nel 1609 e solo dopo secoli fu
pestato effettivamente in una camera a
vuoto dove se ne potete comprovare la
verdicità una palla da bowling ma più ma
cadono effettivamente alla stessa
velocità nel 1971 l'esperimento fu
ripetuto dal durante la missione apollo
15 per me lo scopo didattico sulla
superficie della luna e anche in questo
caso si osservò che i due oggetti che
arrivano alla stessa velocità
eppure questo apparentemente le missioni
apollo in sé per sé hanno rappresentato
un traguardo straordinario per la fisica
è stato il collo sviluppo nel corso dei
secoli della fisica stessa che ci ha
portato a uno dei traguardi come le
missioni apollo la missilistica era
partita decenni prima e con la sospinta
dalla corsa alla sovranità tecnologica
intrapresa tra il capitalismo
occidentale il comunismo sovietico e
culminata con l'invio di 12 uomini sulla
luna
a poco più di 60 anni dal primo volo di
un aereo e questo di per sé dimostra la
straordinarietà dell'impegno dell'uomo
che se effettivamente c'è può realizzare
a risolvere problemi a velocità
realmente impensabili la nasa durante il
picco le dipendenze di dipendenti
raggiunse i circa 400 mila impiegati
diretti e indiretti coinvolgendo
migliaia di industrie e portando allo
sviluppo di tecnologie che avrebbero
altrimenti richiesto decenni per essere
sviluppate poiché apparentemente
complicate
pensate ad esempio al mylar delle
coperte termiche al termometro
infrarosso e l'equipaggiamento dei
pompieri
pensate al teflon la stessa passera che
utilizzate tutti i giorni anche nelle
padelle
pensate alle protesi artificiali gli
omogeneizzati nacquero con il pensate
con il programma umano delle missioni
spaziali così come nuovi standard per la
sicurezza sistemi compatti di
monitoraggio biomedico i purificatori
d'acqua
eppure una delle grandi tecnologie
sviluppate fu anche la pompa cardiaca
tecnologia che fu sviluppata solo grazie
alle medesime tecniche di calcolo fluido
dinamico che vennero sviluppate per
progettare i motori a razzo ma questo è
ancora una volta solo l'apice di quello
che il programma spaziale ha portato
sulla terra e gps satelliti per il
monitoraggio ambientale per la
predizione dei disastri naturali per il
monitoraggio climatico sistemi di
rimozione per le mine materiali memory
foam lenti riflettenti il ultravioletto
i sistemi di telecomunicazione che ci
hanno reso vicino come non mai in questa
era e hanno salvato milioni di vite
eppure tutto ciò effettivamente non
traspariva tutto ciò all'epoca erano
ancora in uno stato troppo primordiale
perché se ne potesse apprezzare il
beneficio e così dopo la luna la nostra
esplorazione si è fermata limitata da un
budget sempre più stretto regolato dall
opinione pubblica ma le cose stanno
cambiando
oggi stiamo vivendo una nuova era del
loro per l'esplorazione spaziale quando
dallo spazio è stato possibile creare
una nuova economia
siamo stati effettivamente in grado di
rivoluzionare l'esplorazione e stavolta
continuare l'esplorazione dello spazio
non sembra solo più plausibile sembra
inevitabile quando dall'esplorazione
riesce a creare profitto come nel caso
della compagnia delle indie allora sì
che veramente si aprono le frontiere e
stavolta la situazione non sembra
diversa molto spesso si sente la frase
siamo troppo giovani per esplorare il
mondo è troppo siamo troppo vecchi per
esplorare il mondo è troppo giovani per
esplorare le stelle ma la verità è che
siamo esattamente nel momento giusto per
essere la generazione che verrà
ricordata come quella del grande salto
per essere realmente la generazione che
avrà contribuito e che sarà stata
partecipa dell'inizio dell'esplorazione
spaziale
oggi ci sono molteplici centinaia di
compagnie aerospaziale in giro per il
mondo su basate sul mercato del
commercio dei satelliti
eppure quelle che sono risorse e come
per esempio l'utilizzo delle risorse
spaziali
oppure la colonizzazione sono
assolutamente più vicine di quanto voi
possiate mai immaginare e da dentro il
settore questa cosa si sente in un modo
incredibile
immaginate di poter usufruire delle
risorse quasi illimitate presenti nello
spazio
e immaginate di non avere più problemi
niente più giochi di potere niente più
sfruttamento dell'umanità per quelle
ridottissime presenti qui sulla terra
niente più guerre per le
forse sfruttamento dell'uomo niente più
catastrofe ecologiche e disastri
ambientali e questo non è un futuro
utopistico distante secoli è una realtà
che giorno dopo giorno ci accingiamo ad
affrontare questo è l'impatto che lo
spazio avuto sulla nostra vita
quotidiana
volevo dire questo è l'impatto che lo
spazio avuto sulla nostra vita
quotidiana
io ho qualche giorno dopo il mio
diciottesimo compleanno ho aperto un
azienda nel settore aerospaziale la
sidereus space dynamics nel tentativo di
provare aiutare come posso
l'esplorazione spaziale
questo perché credo veramente che se
inevitabilmente ciò a cui siamo
destinati ma tutti noi possiamo far
parte di questa avventura
io sto provando a creare un legame
quanto più stretto possibile tra
economia e di ricerca scientifica
provando a sviluppare nuove tecnologie
nel settore
chi siano utili sia nello spazio che
nella vita quotidiana ma tutti possiamo
essere partecipi di questo come beh
semplicemente non facendo mai perdere la
curiosità che ci caratterizza i bambini
non facendo continuando ad avere la
stessa voglia per l'esplorazione che
avevamo in passato e soprattutto
diventando noi stessi parte di questa
nuova avventura coinvolgendoci
coinvolgendo tutti facendo diventare lo
spazio parte del nostro immaginario
collettivo non relegandolo come un
qualcosa di distante e astruso tutti noi
possiamo far parte di ciò ed è questo il
momento di agire ora
adesso che tutto sta iniziando e questo
è il momento di agire qui ora in questo
momento lo spazio in sé per sé per
concludere l'esplorazione più in
generale
generalmente viene abbiamo visto ci ha
salvato più di una volta dell'estinzione
ha plasmato il mondo attorno a noi ci ha
reso effettivamente parte di parte
dell'universo rendendoci in grado di
manipolare le forze della natura e
l'esplorazione in sé per sé non deve
essere stavolta limitata non c'è
tutti possiamo partecipare non c'è
distinzione per età non c'è distinzione
per sesso non c'è distinzione
per etnia o status sociale tutti noi
nelle nostre professioni possiamo
partecipare a c'è soprattutto possiamo
emozionarci per questo la vita deve
essere più che risolvere problemi non è
l'intelligenza non è la guerra non è la
comunicazione che ci di stick distingue
l'uomo da qualsiasi altra specie l'unica
differenza che l'uomo ha rispetto alle
altre specie e il piacere puro di
conoscere la curiosità se l'unica cosa
che ci identifica come unici e per
concludere mi piacerebbe diciamo che
tutto questo discorso si può
sintetizzare con la frase del celebre
padre della missilistica costante in si
offuschi la terra è la culla
dell'umanità ma non siamo destinati per
sempre a rimanere nella culla
grazie
[Applauso]